have you also noticed that youtube
recommendations have been kind of [ __ ]
recently
no i think they've been the opposite
yeah yeah yeah i think might have just
been garbage recently
because you're watching garbage content
yeah there i said it
i said it no more anime man videos to me
then i'm done
i feel like just because you've watched
so much youtube actually
you know that you just run out you run
out of all the good ones
right that's true that's true i mean
it's it's true like any any medium right
yeah [ __ ] maybe
[ __ ] maybe you're right gone i mean
my recommendation has been great because
i've just been watching youtuber clips
so
yeah all of my recommenders is just
youtube clips i haven't seen but
just watch streams at that point right i
mean i do okay yeah
but sometimes i don't want to go through
a three hour stream to watch five
minutes of it right
yeah i mean my and i feel like the best
youtube recommendations is like you know
you know the one video where it gets
recommended and it's just like
it's just like a sub minute video that
has like
five million views they're always end up
being amazing like
my my favorite youtube genres now is
that a title that a title that it says
that does exactly what it's
a video that does exactly what it says
on the title yeah like i remember like
i saw a video the other day that was
like ducks annihilate a bowl of peas
i'm just like all right let this this
can't be right and it's it's just a
[ __ ]
too dark just annihilating these bowls
of peas and i'm just like
this is peak youtube content right now
that's that's like twitter content right
it's like it's like twitter videos
put onto youtube but in terms of like
youtube recommendations i mean there's
only a
certain set of content creators that
like i i would say make
content that you are very invested in
and you like get
excited over when they upload and you
always have you always have that like
boom right of like a certain type of
content yeah like inside of you i mean
we can talk about the youtubers we like
on next week which is going to be the
youtube episode
yes we're gonna talk about our favorite
youtubers it's gonna be the giant shout
out episode
but yeah i mean like i i think youtube
recommendations comes in like waves
right because
you you you like you all it takes is
like one
one video and you recommend it and then
you like recommend your recommendations
like good for like a good like few days
because you're like oh this is a
new kind of like new kind of rabbit hole
that i found myself in but when when
you're in that like lol moments when you
end up watching so much youtube then you
just you just end up watching
you've exhausted the recommendation yeah
you know what sucks about uh
living in japan is that everyone uploads
while we're sleeping so when i wake up
i already know all the videos that are
going to be uploaded during my day
from sub people i'm subscribed to so i
already know like the best videos
when i wake up so i can watch all the
best videos in like the first hour hour
and a half right yeah
and then i have nothing else when i was
living in the uk they were like coming
out gradually
during my evening right yeah it was
always like oh this new video okay go
back i mean i've had that problem my
entire life yeah i know i know
yeah i mean not your time australia yeah
yeah exactly we're only one hour
difference
it's so weird for me because it's like
oh wait okay so all the videos are out
in the morning and i watch it all in the
morning
that's what i like about it it's that
like you wake up in the morning and all
the content is there for that day but it
sucks because when i'm in the middle of
the day and i want to watch something
like there's nothing no one's uploading
anything so it's right but then that's
why it's like
i've never cared about that because i've
always just cared about that
clearly because i'm talking about it
[ __ ] that means youtube upload schedules
actually matter
so we forgot to plug in this pizza yeah
[ __ ] that means youtube upload schedules
actually matter because i thought
everyone was like me
who just like watches videos in the
description or whenever yeah and just
like oh i'll just watch this video when
it when i feel like it i don't
care when it's uploaded i care when it's
uploaded [ __ ]
i don't i don't again like i don't so
much care when it's uploaded because for
me
like my entire like idea of youtube
content for that day has always been
like wake up in the morning
like go down my sub let's be like all
right i'm probably gonna watch this
video this video this video and then i
usually just like watch it as i'm like
having breakfast or getting ready for
the day
and then once i've exhausted that selfie
then i'm like all right now i can go on
with my day and actually do productive
[ __ ]
yeah it's like out of the way now i just
can't do anything until i've watched all
the good videos today
i need my fix of something like honestly
i don't think there's
that much good content out there where
i'm just i'm just like i need good con
like i don't there's not enough content
out there that's good in my mind that
can keep me entertained every day
you know what i mean there's like
certain youtubers where i'm like it's a
banger video and i know i'm gonna enjoy
this but
most of the youtube content you watch is
just fills the time and that's
that's just it and it's just like can
this fill the time without me getting
bored
isn't it weird that like i don't know if
this is just me but like
has it gone to the point now where like
the sub feed has just basically turned
into like a timeline just to see what
everyone's doing
you know it's like it's kind of
something like a youtube timeline i'm
like alright let's see what people are
doing today
and it's like you don't you don't watch
80 of the videos that are on your selfie
but you just still sub to them because
you're wondering like all right what are
they up to now like
yeah it's weird how that's becoming feel
bad when i don't watch youtubers video
oh my god oh my god we're all very tired
today we're very tired this has already
been the most tired i think we've all
been for a trash day's episode like i
slept horribly gone
went to bed at 6 00 a.m and joey's tired
too
i'm always tired right but you were
saying you feel bad when i feel bad when
i don't keep up with youtubers
especially if i know though i'm like oh
man i just i didn't watch that new video
if you i'm sorry man the [ __ ] i'm a bad
friend
have you always done that though with
like like i should keep up with all my
friends
mate yeah i try and keep up just so i
can like be like oh no man nah she
killed it like if they did something
really ambitious i'd love to like i
don't know be like hey man you [ __ ]
killed it bro nice i don't know if
that's a rare
thing because my general understanding
is like again it's like
people just sub to you to like you know
show support of course but also to be
like just to
see what's up with that i'm not just
different for every viewer like this one
i'm sure not everyone watches every
episode of trash tastes right or cares
about when it comes out like i'll give
you even though you should
you should be watching every trash taste
episode yeah
anyway this has been a very weird two
hour i hope you've enjoyed the two-hour
therapy session between the boys yeah
this has been like the least like i feel
like exciting episodes
we're all just [ __ ] tired of [ __ ] and
we're like what are we talking about
it's just basically just addicts
anonymous i'm addicted to this hello
hello i'm addicted to the internet and
you need to take a break and con is just
like i don't have an issue i don't know
where you oh maybe i do have an issue
with the shittiest like i don't have an
issue therefore you don't have an issue
my league
issue my youtube issue man what what's
an axe dude do you want
you want me to fix your league issue
just quit just stop at least heroin is
still good